et bien non
[Musique]
les enfants récupèrent leurs lampions la
barbe à papa et ont roulé le pop comme
souffler la fête de la saint-jacques de
bois d'arcy bat son plein depuis trois
ans elle a lieu sur la place truffaut du
quartier de la croix bonnet et remporté
un réel succès auprès des habitants
il y aura trois les personnes qui vont
passer à la fête c'est une très grosse
fête
c'est une des plus grosses fêtes refaite
du territoire c'est très très important
le démarrage a eu lieu avec le plein air
qu'on a fait jeudi soir au cinéma sur la
tramblais là ce soir avec le bal et puis
quand je voulais dit la fête du sport
les trophées du sport le forum des
associations plein de choses donc ça
draine beaucoup beaucoup de monde et
pour rythmer tous à la batucada fait
vibrer les tambours et danser les
familles à 6e
[Musique]
les habitants cherchent à se retrouver
et profiter des animations
un seul mot d'ordre faire la fête le
rassemblement tous ensemble le feu
d'artifice grandes stars de la fête à
trouver son public
et pour ceux qui voulaient peaufiner
leurs meilleurs pas de danse les
festivités se sont poursuivies avec le
traditionnel bal